before getting into the video I wanted
to quickly mention my Etsy shop where I
sell bookmarks and prints and I have a
few King Killer Chronicle related things
in there so if you are interested I will
leave a link in the description below
also quick spoiler warning for the name
of the wind and the Wise Man's Fear
you're gonna want to read both of those
man there are some amazing fan theories
out there for the Kingkiller Chronicle
in fact there's a few that I'm almost
positive are true and if you disagree
well you can fight me in smash bros dude
because there is so much proof
especially with the theory I'm just
about to mention also I just feel like
playing smash bros all of a sudden one
such theory that I'm quite confident in
is the theory that caboose mother Lori n
is in fact a Natalia lack less and I
really think we're gonna see this
confirmed in the yet to be released
third book the doors of stone the lack
less family now the lack this family is
one of the oldest families in all of
Ventus their lineage goes back farther
than a millennium and really it's
probably older than that but
unfortunately the burning of calop tena
destroyed many of the family records
throughout history their family name has
been changed from things like low close
to lock loss or last lift but in
convulse current time they're known as
lack 'less however it's important to
note that these all translate back to
lock lists this name relates to a legend
about a secret door on their family
estate which has no handles hinges or
locks this kind of sound similar to the
lock list box and I'll be talking about
the lock list box later on in this video
there's some long history about the lack
less family ruling over mode egg and
Ventus and falling on hard times with
peasant revolts and assassination but
today we're just gonna focus on the
importance of the lack less family and
how they relate to give oath as I'm sure
you all remember in the Wiseman's fear
could both travels to Ventus to obtain a
right of patronage from Merrill Veron
who in fact has about as much power as
the king of Ventus himself Rodrick :
'this now after discovering the mayors
being poisoned by his very own Alchemist
kavod has given the job to put his
poetic talent to use and win the heart
of malla 1 lakh lists for the mayor as
he wishes
to marry her both kind of struggles with
inspiration for this task until he
begins to think of his feelings for
denna
he's then able to write the letters that
are given to mallow in and sure enough
she's woo I mean key both is a smooth
talker
both is then given yet another job this
time he has to lead a group of
mercenaries and hunt down a group of
bandits who we figure out are being led
by cinder one of the CH and Riaan some
other things happen after this we'll
skip over most of it but can both later
ends up in the Pharaon where he meets a
creature and known as the cafe who
advises kavod to sit close to the mayor
and he will lead him to the door of the
emir yeah I would still be cautious on
what the cafe tells me that thing is not
trustworthy upon his return could both
me to Marwan and the mayor and they show
him a lack less family heirloom a box
that has no visible lid or locks now
trust me we will be getting back to this
box in a little bit but first let's talk
about what's going on here so kavod
mentions that he finds mal Owens
appearance to be very familiar though he
can't quite place it he says the
resemblance isn't from the University or
from Emery during this same encounter
mal one discovers kavod is of a demo
rube Lud and she quickly shows her
prejudice and dislike for Co both and
she dismisses him from Ventus now why
does malwan dislike the ademma Roux at
this much here's where things get
interesting we learned that mala Wan
Lockleys had a sister named Natalia who
ran off with a group of traveling
performers when she was young and has
since been disowned from the family this
means the only heir to the Lachlan Leah
is Malin so this kind of explains why
she hates the ademma roof so much
because she thinks they stole her sister
away but could it be her sister actually
fell in love with in a demo room how now
this is where we can start to piece
things together starting with a poem
written by kvass father our lledon to
his wife dark Lorien our lead-ins wife
has a face like a blade of a knife has a
voice like a prickle down bur but can
Talia som like a moneylender my sweet
tele cannot cook but she keeps a tidy
ledger book for all her faults I do
confess it's worth my life to make my
wife not tally
a lot less it's important to note the
three words being repeated here in the
fourth line tally is being used as an
action to tally up a sum but in the
fifth line my suite tally it's being
used as a nickname perhaps for Natalia
now the next time we see the word tally
is in the final line and usually that
means it's pretty important to focus on
this is a very clever header a graph a
header a graph is a group of words that
sound the same as other words in this
case not tally a lot less sounds like
Natalia lacus it's almost like Rothfuss
put this in there as like a clever code
for us to figure out and I just I love
it when authors do stuff like this for
me that's enough proof right there also
the way that loriann reacts to this
she's not really too happy and she makes
arla didn't spend the night underneath
of the wagon you gotta love this couple
now the next piece of evidence comes
from a riddle that can both learned from
a young girl when he was a child and he
absent mindedly repeated this to his mom
seven things has lady Lachlan keeps them
underneath her black dress what a ring
that's not for wearing one a sharp word
not for swearing right beside her
husband's candle there's a door without
a handle in a box no litter locks lack
lists keeps her husband's rocks there's
a secret she's been keeping she's been
dreaming and not sleeping on a road
that's not for traveling lack las' likes
her riddle raveling now his mother
scolds him for this because of the
suggestive innuendo but she also
mentions how the rumors about lady lack
lists are just gossip she seems to be
pretty offended and maybe that's because
she is Natalia Lac las' I think we
solved the mystery guys but wait there's
more now as mentioned earlier later in
kaavo's life he has to lead a party of
mercenaries to defeat a group of bandits
that were led by cinder now after this
they come across a group of performers
where a young boy is reciting a
different version of the same rhyme
seven things stand before the entrance
to the Lac list door one of them a ring
unworn one a word that is forsworn
one a time that must be right one a
candle without light one a son who
brings the blood one adore that hole
the flood one a thing tight held in
keeping then comes that which comes with
sleeping this seems to be a list of
seven different things needed to open
the lock this door and it lines up quite
well with the first version now we
actually know where these seven
different things are because in the
first version it says lady lack lists
keeps them under her black dress that
sounds a bit odd
I know but assuming lady Lachlan is Lyra
it might kind of make sense now you
might remember the story of laundry and
lira lira was a powerful neighbor who
resurrected laundry during the Battle of
dross and tour also known as the black
of dross and tour I saw somebody
mentioned this on reddit and it kind of
makes sense to me I feel like it fits in
with her black dress maybe her black
dress is the black of dross and tour
so maybe the battlegrounds of dross on
tour is where you can find these items I
don't know it's worth a thought moving
on to the first item a ring unworn or a
ring that's not for wearing now there
are a lot of different rings in these
books I mean there's the wooden ring
that Malin gives to kavod to mark him as
a rooh there's all the rings that he
gets in Ventus
there's also Deniz ring actually Patrick
Rothfuss made a replica of Deniz ring
which has yulish knots on it by the way
so that's a very important ring but
there is actually an entire poem about
the rings that kvass supposedly wears
later in his life but I'd like to point
out the final line where he's wearing a
ring that has no name now I'm not really
sure what this can be
I mean it's hinted at throughout the
book that copper doesn't have a name so
maybe it's a ring of copper I don't know
next is a word that is forsworn or a
sharp word not for swearing maybe the
name of a CH and Riaan I know you're not
supposed to mention their names a time
that must be right I don't know a candle
without light now this also goes into
the first version where it says right
beside her husband's candle now Lyra's
husband was lon ray and lon ray if you
know the story he was a legendary hero
who had a downfall and he's the one who
became Hallie axe and started the CH and
Riaan he's the leader of the CH and
Riaan and where was a candle without
light mentioned well at the moth and
farm at when that
was dug up and there's a picture of
Hallie axe there's also a description of
two candles and I quote next to him were
two candles one was yellow with a bright
orange flame the other candle sat
underneath his outstretched hand it was
gray with a black flame and the space
around it was smudged and darkened you
know that kind of defeats the purpose of
a candle like it doesn't even make light
its is it even a candle moving on a son
who brings the blood this seems to mean
that only a male member of the lack less
bloodline can open up the door
so if Co both is in fact Natalia lack
Lass's son then he would qualify for
opening that door and considering he's
the main protagonist and he I'm sure he
probably is that person one a door that
holds the flood now I think this door
holds back the Fae realm so all of the
creatures of the Fae
this would kind of explain why there is
fake creatures leaking into the human
world in coats lifetime because we see
scray land and demon like creatures that
are coming into the human realm probably
because this door has been opened what a
thing tied held in keeping now I think
this is the item which is inside of the
lack less box which over here it says
that lack less keeps her husband's rocks
inside of the box and I don't think it's
what you're thinking now I think her
husband's rocks are the same as shards
of mountain glass that Sulli toes used
to gouge out his eye to bind long reign
now cielito sand laundry used to kind of
be friends until a laundry turned into
Hallie axe and started destroying cities
so saludos had to stop him in some way
by binding him and giving him the signs
that Hallie axe is known to have now a
fine verse 10 kind of interesting she's
been dreaming and not sleeping now Lyra
should be dead I'm wondering if this is
trying to indicate that she's not
actually dead maybe she's stuck in a
sort of dreamlike state
maybe she's Ori that's a theory for a
whole nother video so with all of this
proof kvass mother could very well have
been a lot less making Kavitha
laccoliths making it mala one his aunt
who hates Adam Aroo but if it's proven
that he's a lack list this would make
him an even more important air than
Ambrose not to mention he qualifies for
opening the
Lock lists door and I think this door is
the same door of the Emir that the
Cathay talks about and perhaps the flood
being held behind the door is the PHA
realm and once the door is opened these
two realms are going to intermingle with
scroll and fate creatures coming into
the human realm now this is all assuming
that Lady lack lists is Lyra and I'm
quite positive in this because of the
candle thing the only time a candle
without light is mentioned is when it's
talking about Holly axe and Holly axes
wife was Lyra this also takes me back to
the legend of londre when he became
Holly axe and he destroyed seven of the
eight cities some of the people in the
cities ended up joining him forming the
Chand rien now I wonder if the people
that joined him are of lack less blood
maybe the chandran is all lack less
blood growth you got some weird
relatives dude there are just so many
different theories for the Kingkiller
Chronicle like going into this video I
was just expecting to focus on the
theory of Laurie and being Natalie lack
'less but how could I mention that
without bringing up the Loch listbox
or without bringing up the luckless door
so I kind of had to bring a few into
this but make sure to tell me any
theories that you know of down below and
I might just make a video on them anyway
guys I should get back to desperately
waiting for the doors of stone
whose spooky black flames but what
purpose does that have